[Music]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
this
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
you
my
[Music]
so
hey everyone good evening welcome to the
table
my name is karen miner i am so glad
you're with us tonight
um as you can see i have a little bit of
a different setup than usual which means
i can see who is on the live stream
right now so i just wanted to say
a few hellos to uh let's see i saw
raymond and nancy and
adam marshall ashley
uh who else marissa
um
[Music]
and joe yeah so i'm really really glad
you're here it's so great to see your
names pop
up as you join us please
just put a comment uh let us know you're
watching
i want to make sure we can welcome you
personally um
i just have one announcement for tonight
we have our second ever state of the
table
meeting coming up it's going to happen
on sunday
august 23rd it will be online and
basically what the state of the table is
is kind of like state of the union it's
where we take some time to talk about
um just our financials
our vision for the rest of the year kind
of take a snapshot of
our community overall and so if that's
something that interests you
we would love for you to be a part of it
it's open to anybody who's interested
so for now save the date for sunday
august 23rd
for our online state of the table
meeting and we'll follow up with
more details soon um so
this is the first sunday of august and i
was thinking back to when we used to
meet in person
and how the first sunday of every month
was traditionally called first sundays
at the table and
we would share communion together during
the service
and then immediately following the
service we would have a community meal
and i really i just can't express enough
how much
i miss those times but as i was
reflecting and thinking about
communion and the way jesus talked about
communion as he as he
had the last supper with the disciples
the symbolism
and the theme there is all about
remembrance and
he was saying do this in remembrance of
me
knowing that he was not going to
physically be with them for a while
and i think that's instructive for us
right now in this season when we're not
able to meet together
physically but we want to stay
just spiritually connected and connected
as a community
and i think just that remembrance of
communion
was more than just the the eating of the
bread and the drinking of the wine or
the juice
it's really that communal connection
um and spiritual connection like i think
it's in colossians two where
uh it talks about jesus being in all
things and holding together all things
so as we center on jesus
uh that reminds us who we are
who jesus is and that we are all
connected
even though we can't be physically
together
and when we did do communion together
one of my favorite parts of that was
when brett
would read a celtic invitation to the
table
and so i wanted to read that tonight
so that we can remember we can remember
each other
we can remember that we are a community
it's also an invitation
so if you are just joining us for the
first time
you are welcome at the table if this is
all new to you
christianity jesus you are welcome at
the table
uh everyone has a seat and it's
the table that is centered on jesus not
the church
so here goes
this is the table not of the church but
of the lord
it is made ready for those who love him
and for those who want to love him more
so come you who have much faith
and you who have little you who have
been here often
and you who have not been here long
you who have tried to follow and you who
have failed
come because because it is the lord who
invites you
and it is his will that those who want
to meet him
should meet him here come to the table
[Music]
come all proud come all
greedy come all lies come all
[Music]
come all broken come on needy
come all poor and come all slaves
come all rulers
come all sinners come all saints
come to the table
from near and far
come from the shadows
out of the dark
this room at the table
we saved you a season
[Music]
every race every
nation come all rebels come
all day from the fringes come
to jesus to a table
full of the grace
come and stay come to the table
come eat and dream
there's no inner circle
[Music]
come let down your guide
you're never a stranger
just come as you are
come be home
[Music]
come now come
accepted
[Music]
the party is waiting
there's more still to feed
and the harvest is ready
go fill every seat
[Music]
as a kingdom of priests
love
[Music]
come now come
come now
[Music]
sometimes on this journey
i get lost in my mistakes
what looks to me like weakness
is a canvas for your strength
my story isn't over
my story's just begun
fear you won't define me cause that's
what my father does
fail you won't you find me that's what
my father does
here in the father's house
check your shape at the door cause it
ain't welcome anymore
ooh you're in the
father's house
arrival's not the end game the journey's
where you are
you never want it perfect you just
wanted my heart
and the story isn't over if the story
isn't good
failure's never final when the father's
in the room
i said failure's never final when the
father's in the
[Music]
your room down
here in the father's house check your
shame at the door
is it a welcome anymore you're in the
father's house
you're in the father's house
there's no shame here
prodigals come home help us find hope
love is on the moon when the father's in
the room
[Music]
miracles take place the sinner could
find
faith love is breaking through
when the father's in the room
jericho's walls are quaking strongholds
now is shaken
love is breaking through when the
father's in the room
[Music]
lay your burdens
the down house check his shame
at the door cause it ain't welcome
anymore
oh whoa you're in the father's house
[Music]
there's no shame here
accept
come now come
come behold
come be loved
accepted
come now come
you're in the father's house
[Music]
so
your love o lord
reaches to the heavens
your faithfulness
stretches to the sky
your righteousness
it's like a mighty mountain
your justice
[Music]
i flows the ocean time
let's sing that again
reaches to the heavens
to the skies
[Music]
your righteousness
it's like a mighty mountain
[Music]
your justice flows
like the ocean tide
[Music]
and i will find my strength
in the shadow of your
ways
and i will lift my voice
to worship you my
dream
and i will find my
[Music]
your love oh
reaches to the heavens
[Music]
your faithfulness
stretches to the skies
[Music]
your righteousness
is like a mighty mountain
[Music]
your justice flows
like the ocean
[Music]
i can see
beneath
[Music]
my voice
to worship you my king
[Music]
and i will find myself
and i will lift my
voice to worship you
my king
and i will find my strength
in the shadows
[Music]
reaches to the heavens
your faithfulness
stretches to the skies
[Music]
your righteousness
is like a mighty mountain
justice flows like the oceans
[Music]
your love o lord
reaches to the havens
your faithfulness
stretches to the skies
well good evening everyone
thank you josh and gary and karen um
grace and peace
to you all uh welcome to the table it's
really really good to be
back with you all after a few weeks off
and
a huge huge thank you to um so many
people who
filled in for me while i was out um
see we had i know don jacobs he spoke
and josh brock and of course maggie
tilford last week and then uh karen
and gary and juanita and mindy really
all um kind of stepped up in various
ways
um just to help uh kind of prep for
sundays
uh some of it behind the scenes to get
ready so i'm just yeah really really
grateful
thank you for giving me some time it was
a good few weeks
i did just a staycation you know covet
and all
so um but it was it was good it's
there's something about taking some
space to just kind of renew
uh you know your own heart soul mind and
i experienced that it was great so
um yeah but i'm really glad really glad
to be uh
back and and i also think you know
sometimes it takes um
it takes me being away to show that the
table it really is
all of us together you know it's not
just like the brett show
the pastor show whatever but it's a
collective of people
all following christ and learning to
love one another um
and our world so um yeah so
so glad that you can be with us and i'm
glad to be back
all right so we're in uh let's see part
seven in our series
on the gospel of luke and the title of
my message tonight
is a radiant light
and our primary text is going to be luke
chapter 11 verses 33-36
where jesus said no one lights a lamp
and then hides it or puts it under a
basket
instead a lamp is placed on a stand
where its light can be seen by all who
enter
the house your eye is like a lamp that
provides
light for your body when your eye is
healthy
your whole body is filled with light
but when it is unhealthy your body is
filled with darkness make sure that the
light you think you have
is not actually darkness if you're
filled with light with no dark corners
then your whole
life will be radiant as though
a floodlight were filling you with light
all right so to grasp this text i think
we need to understand how
jesus as a first century jewish person
likely
understood sight so the capacity to see
is one of those things that's really
easy to just take for granted
but the fact that we have this uh
this you know sense organ that perceives
light bouncing off of objects and then
hitting the cones and cells in our eyes
which then travels nearly
instantaneously to our brains where it's
then interpreted
and this whole process is happening all
day every day
uh i mean this is just a complete
miracle
and i think understanding the modern
science
of sight at least in my opinion does not
make this um any less miraculous
so so this this miracle of of sight was
of course reflected on
in jesus day as well granted you know it
was two thousand years ago
also very different culture um obviously
there's no such thing as like modern
science but they were still doing kind
of you know their own
philosophy and their own kind of
rudimentary science to kind of
understand
um you know what was happening so of
course they reflected on scene like how
is this
miracle happening and so one theory that
apparently based on this passage in luke
11 that jesus he seems to have
understood or kind of held to in some
way was something called the extra
mission
theory of vision so the extra mission
theory it posits
that the viewer right that would be like
you or i possesses
an inner light that flows
through the eyes forming rays that are
sent out toward visible objects
so this was a very popular theory of
vision of scene at the time of jesus
the greek mathematician philosopher
pythagoras he seems to be the first
person who
kind of developed this this view this
theory
and then it later came to be held by
people like plato
uh the early church father origin even
saint augustine
so the idea was basically that your
inner light
begins in like the core of who you are
you can call it the soul
and then it flows out as i described
kind of out
through your eyes and then it connects
with the sunlight
in the external world where it then
transmits back to your eyes and
is then made sense of uh by your like
mind or they call it a soul
so one way to think um of this
this kind of theory is that it really
understands
sight as almost a form of touch
where this light that is from you
uh and thus in some sense kind of is you
where it goes out
into the world and connects with other
things
and potentially impacts them transforms
them right interacts with them and then
it returns to you
and now has the potential to transform
you all right
so now you say but scientifically
speaking
uh that is not how sight actually works
um that's true i know
um but the thing is i don't think it
actually matters
because jesus is not trying to make a
scientific argument here
instead he's using this as a metaphor
to talk about something else and that
something else in my reading of this
text
is your inner light this this
inner quality of a person the idea seems
to be
that you are always already radiating
a certain light a a vibe
at the risk of uh sounding a little
woo-woo
and i think it's okay i've said before
i'm a christian and that means i'm a
little bit woo-woo
um but basically i mean he's kind of
describing that you're radiating
this you know this energy um this vibe
and we i think we pick up on this in one
another right
um for example there are certain people
you just want to be around
right certain people that they're they
radiate a
light a a goodness a positivity of
being that draws you toward them
in fact when you're around them it's
it's almost like their
life light has has touched you
um has changed you interact with you for
the better
now i'm very biased uh on this but i
think
that those of you who know her will
agree that for example
my wife maggie is one of those people if
you've got
the privilege of listening last week she
spoke last week um
did a really wonderful job and she she
is she's just one of those people now
by most standards maggie has lived a
very quiet and simple life
she goes to church she loves her friends
she's raised three babies
she teaches piano lessons uh you know
simple
quiet life uh but for anyone who like
really knows her
uh she is extraordinary because
of her i think as jesus would call it of
this
light the quality of her light it just
it blazes very
strong uh so much so that when piano
students graduate high school
some of them have only half jokingly
said uh that they're going to just
continue to pay her money
not to take piano lessons but to simply
sit next to her for half an hour every
week
now why would they joke about doing that
because for them
it wasn't just about the piano lessons
was it
it was time to be in the light
now i could be inching my way towards
heresy
making my wife sound like some sort of
uh i don't know like a demigod or
something
so let's make this really clear um who
is the
source of the light
in each of us uh let's make it's really
clear
god if you're taking notes you can write
that down god it this is who christians
call
the holy spirit right god within us
the the spirit of jesus who as
john chapter 1 verse 9 says enlightens
every man every woman every person that
god
is there god is within you which means
the question is not do i have
the light right the question is
well and i said let me back that up a
little bit um it's not do i have light
because god is present to every single
one of us
so the question is how brightly
will i allow it to burn and
and just to be clear this is not about
being a bubbly person
i know very quiet people who i believe
the light
burns white hot in um
i'm just thinking of people like in our
community roy parker
definitely comes to mind now he's far
less bubbly and extroverted
than maggie um and even then his wife
nikki who's
um also radiates the light beautifully
there maggie and nicky are very like
high energy bubbly
roy's not like that but uh but there's
an ease of being
there's there's a love there's a life
light there that i just think
um cannot be denied so
this of course begs the question uh how
can we become people of the light
i think verse 33 puts it really
beautifully um
no one lights a lamp jesus says and then
hides it
or puts it under a basket very few
people in other words
um they just very few people set out
saying i don't want to radiate the light
i want to be evil like
who says that very few people say that
we we all want to be radiant with the
light
and yet you know
i'm often not so radiant um like why why
do
why aren't we as jesus said in verse 34
a a healthy that was his word
healthy people um why do we have
dark corners in our lives as verse 35
says and by the way that's true of all
of us even maggie and roy and nikki
you know all the people um we all have
those dark corners
um so and and so why aren't we as verse
36 says
radiant as though a floodlight
were filling you well here um i'll just
speak from my own experience i think the
reason honestly
is not super complicated it's quite
simple why don't i radiate the light
because it's hard it's harder
i mean what's easy uh is to let
those dark corners of my life become
dark rooms until i have metaphorically
speaking nearly extinguished the light
right left to myself just left my own
little ego
and my own flesh like i just want to
take the easy way out
and in the end i kind of wonder if
perhaps
this is is actually what in ways like
the whole spiritual life boils down to
that there are two paths um the
the kind of go with the flow right the
easy path
what jesus and other passages like in
matthew he calls it the broad way
right just the easy way through life um
or the narrow way the hard way
and the truth is it's it's harder at
least up front i think you know the way
things play
out in the long game it's often easier
and better
to choose the hard thing in the moment
right but i'm so i'm talking about
though in the short run in the immediate
moment
it's harder to choose the light
now what do i mean i mean that every day
uh me and you we are all faced by
hundreds perhaps thousands of just
small decisions that all ask me to
decide
um which will i choose
do i choose the light
i have uh one kiddo
and i've been um struggling with him
recently and
uh he and i have two he's so you're not
quite sure who i'm talking about but he
um just it's been difficult and
um i think in ways i don't have to go
off to like a monastery to receive
intense spiritual training
i just have to try to earn a living and
raise three children
and so this one ghetto has been it's
just it was rough he's just been talking
back a lot and is
just kind of a rude person and this is
particularly true prior to quarantine
lots of mom and dad time the last few
months that's been a good thing that's
been a win
uh prior to that lord have mercy
he's just turning turning into a jerk
and so
uh and not even like occasionally like
pretty much every day and like for
example i would say all right time to go
to bed and he'd say you go to bed
and it's 9 30 at night and i'm just
tired and that may not sound
like much but just go ahead and multiply
that moment by 10 000 moments in the
last few years and it's
uh maggie and i have said it's like
living with an emotionally abusive
person
and so there's times where i just can't
take it anymore so the other day we're
on a family walk
and this kiddo he just been rude you
know all day and
he's riding a scooter and he slipped in
the mud
and fell you know all the way to the
ground and he
wailed and got very dramatic and i
became you know very annoyed because i
was just out of mercy for him
and we kind of continued on um you know
he eventually got up moved on and we
but but on our way back we kind of did a
you know out and back thing so as we're
coming back we came to that
same bend in the path where he had
slipped
and i uh somewhat passive-aggressively
said uh hey bud
do you want me to carry you and your
scooter over this part
just to make sure you don't get hurt
but i said it in that kind of ambiguous
way where it's unclear
if i was lovingly offering to help or
just being a sarcastic jerk
and he looked at me uh kind of trying to
interpret uh before looking away and
kind of he just eventually
kind of you know he couldn't quite read
it and so he just kind of scooted on
ahead
and maggie my wife she turned to me and
she said
why do you do that you see
that that button that insecurity and you
just have to
push it and i don't remember
what i said to her exactly but uh i know
the reason
it's because i'm a jerk and it was
easier
to to blow off steam in that way
than to bite my tongue it's easier
in that small little moment to just keep
this little corner in the darkness
rather than choosing the light
now that may sound small almost not
worth mentioning
but but i name it as an example of the
1 000 small decisions that all
ask us to decide which will we
choose do we choose the light
but it doesn't end there in fact verse
35 takes things even
deeper jesus continues
make sure that the light you think you
have
is not actually darkness
now i think this should put the fear of
the lord in all of us
because it's saying that that there's a
moment
when we believe we are in the light
in fact you might even say we we believe
in that moment we are most in the light
like we've never been
more in the light and yet that just may
be
our darkest moment i was reflecting on
where this is likely to happen in our
lives and i think it's
in our views our opinions and our
judgments
we are sure we are just so sure that we
are stinking right and thus that we are
in
the light about 10 years ago
i was driven to just read and study
christian theology
a lot just very intensely because i
thought like that would be the key
if only i and other christians were more
educated
we would no longer be deluded by wrong
thinking deluded by the darkness
and we would then possess the light but
then i noticed
that the people i was following online
um
the people whose blogs i was reading
remember blogs we used to read things
i mean these people like i was following
they really were honestly they were
brilliant
they were far smarter than me or like
anyone
i knew and uh and yet
over time i could see
their insecurities bleeding through
i could see that they too were
full of ego
they were right and everyone else was an
idiot and
it was like totally immature and and i
noticed that in the very moment
they believed that they and their blogs
you know were bastions of the light
and yet i could see the evil
lurking there because when everything
for you is dogma and the love
is draining out of your heart you are
almost certainly in the darkness uh
here's how theologian dom
allred graham he puts it in his
wonderful book uh
zen catholicism which isn't
isn't it's that's way less heretical
than it sounds that book it's really
wonderful
but he he says this clinging blindly to
one's opinions
can be a more effective block to direct
contact with reality and therefore to
union with god
than vice itself that's a mouth full so
let me read it one more time
clinging blindly to one's opinions
can be a more effective block to direct
contact with reality
and therefore to union with god then
vice
itself what's he saying he's saying that
we
tend to focus on you know the
big sense the the vices the
the i don't know the embarrassing
um you know alcoholism drug abuse you
know etc
when it comes to things that we believe
block the light
but what if what if it's our
stubbornness
and pride what if it's it's our
our opinions and our dogmas and the way
not so much just what we believe but
how we believe it how we hold what we
believe
that are actually the dark corners
we should be most worried about
precisely because
we don't even realize the darkness that
may be dwelling there
because that means at the very moment we
are trying to take the strongest stand
for the light
we actually stand on the precipice of
pride and ego
in thus of a certain darkness
of course the reverse is also true that
those who
can hold their convictions with a
certain gentleness
an awareness of their own fragility and
humanity
although that person might not be nearly
as loud and confident they just might be
radiant with the light as gk chesterton
said angels can fly because they take
themselves
lightly i love that
uh and i guess all i'm saying is that
it's it's really
it's really hard to let the light of god
shine through us
and i don't want to sugarcoat that um if
it were easy human society would be
completely awesome
but there are insecurities and impulses
and all manner of ego and foolishness
just whispering to us to take the easy
road
so uh so what should we do well what i
want to do is close with four
steps uh to radiate the light so if
you're practically minded
um and you want it like broken down this
is the part for you so
here's four steps number one uh take the
hard road
if it's super easy like i described
earlier you know if it's super easy in
the moment if it just feels impulsively
good
uh be real suspicious and if it's
challenging if it takes some discipline
it's that's probably good for you
and i think this really covers
everything from engaging spiritual
disciplines which i have and will
continue to push you towards things like
journaling and prayer scripture reading
meditation
therapy silence um even things like
working out eating well getting the rest
you need like
all those things and then all the way to
the thousand little decisions that we
talked about earlier
um i mean think of that moment with my
son right it's it's easy to be passive
aggressive it is
hard to bite my tongue right so we've
got to choose love
choose service choose humility choose
patience
um choose honest and life giving speech
over and over and over again we got to
take the hard road
uh second take the first step
on the hard road it's easy to get
overwhelmed
by needing to do a thousand things
differently in order to radiate the
light
so just start with one uh choose one
maybe it's
one spiritual discipline maybe it's it's
one right decision
um as i discussed a few weeks ago that
phrase that i got a lot of feedback on
this that was really positive keep your
world
small right so don't get overwhelmed by
the thousand things
keep your world smart shoot small choose
the one
thing um third find a few people
to take the first step on the hard road
with you
uh we live in a society that is so prone
to individualism
and chronic loneliness and the truth is
we all
need a band of brothers a circle of
sisters to engage this path with us um
it's really people who will give us what
we call
um s-e-a support encouragement
accountability
we need all three of those in our life
and that's why we have meetups
so um if you aren't a part of a meet-up
i encourage you to join one
um you can reach out to me or fill out
our contact form at thetabletx.org
and we'll uh we'll get you connected
with with a group uh and then fourth and
finally
pray just look around the world
um on the whole human beings are really
struggling to radiate the light
uh and that includes me and i struggle
you struggle
and this is why we need to realize that
you know it's not just about
you know choosing the hard thing and
taking the hard path and all that
gritting our teeth
um at the end of the day we also all of
us need divine
grace we need to touch the source
of life of light of love
christ himself so that we can receive
that grace and more beautifully
radiate the light of christ
so let me go ahead and pray for us lord
jesus
we we long to be people of the light
so would you move through us
would you give us your grace
god to be faithful to live and love well
and in those little moments when it's
just so easy to take the easy path god
would you
um give us the strength to choose the
hard path
um to radiate the light and because of
that god may we
as as families as friendships as
communities as
the the table this church community god
may we
radiate the light of christ it's the
name of christ that i pray
amen
[Music]
oh my god shine your light
on
on us that if we
might live
i will hold on
it's all that is inside of me
screams to come back
[Music]
if you feel tired
singing along
[Music]
if you feel lost and tired
this is your song
[Music]
love will come back around
if you feel lost
[Music]
if you
feel tired
sing along
you feel lost
you feel lost and tired
this is your song
oh my god shine your light
on us
[Music]
oh my god shine your light
on us that we
might feel
oh my god shine your light
on us that we
might lead
thanks josh thank you brett for that
message
i really really needed to hear that
i don't know about you guys but this
past week i have really been struggling
to radiate the light
and specifically around just navigating
this whole back to school stuff
like what do we do and how do we make
informed decisions and oh gosh
and i know at the table we've got so
many
families of school-aged kids we've got
teachers and school staff
and i just want you to know that
you know we're in this together and
we are praying for you guys as a table
leadership team and um
yeah that's right we need each other in
this we need support encouragement
accountability
that's what the church is for um and to
ground all of that in the fruit of the
spirit
and goodness and faithfulness and
patience and peace
and we need to remind each other of that
and that it's all centered on god so
whether it's around the school stuff or
anything else that
is going on in your life right now we
want to be there for you
so please please reach out if there's
something we can help you with
practically or tangibly
or prayerfully or just a listening ear
that that's who we are that's the table
um and
also i i really really want to thank
those of you that are continuing to give
whether it's financially or
energetically or with your presence
to the table it means so much especially
right now
these are you know these these can be
really stressful tough times it can be
easy to tap out and take a break
and so many of you have chosen to just
keep showing up and just want to say
thank you
it does not go unnoticed and it's really
really appreciated
so as we close out tonight
i wanted to take a moment to acknowledge
and honor
the passing of a giant among us a civil
rights leader and u.s congressman john
lewis
shortly before he died he wrote an op-ed
that he wanted
to have published the day of his funeral
so it just got released and it's it's
incredible
um i'm going to read an excerpt of it
as our benediction and call to action
tonight but if you get a chance i highly
recommend reading it in its entirety
so these are the words of john lewis may
he rest in peace
and power though i may not be here with
you
i urge you to answer the highest calling
of your heart
and stand up for what you truly believe
in my life i have done all i can to
demonstrate
that the way of peace the way of love
and non-violence is the more excellent
way
now it is your turn to let freedom ring
when historians pick up their pens to
write the story of the 21st century
let them say that it was your generation
who laid down the heavy burdens of hate
at last and that peace finally triumphed
over violence
aggression and war so i say to you
walk with the wind brothers and sisters
and let the spirit of
peace and the power of everlasting love
be your guide amen
be blessed as you go into your week
we're here for you however you need us
to be
and we hope to see you back here next
week bye
you